صحيح يستمر القصف الاسرائيلي في محيط
المجمع بالاضافه الى اطلاق الرصاص هذه
الان صوره مباشره لاستهداف قوات الاحتلال
سياره مدنيه كانت تحاول التنقل ما بين
مكان الى اخر هذا المفترق الذي تقف عليه
الدبابه يبدو ان المواطنون لا يعرفون ان
هنا ان في هذا المكان تتواجد قوات
الاحتلال في ظل انقطاع الاتصال وانقطاع
الانترنت وانقطاع حتى شبكات الراديو
وانقطاع الكهرباء يبدو
ان من انتقل من الشارع الى الاخر لا يعرف
ان هنا قوات الاحتلال تتواجد بكثافه رغم
اطلاق الرصاص الكثيف يبدو ان الكثير من
المواطنين تعودوا على هذا الرصاص وهذه
الطلقات بسبب استمرار الحرب ل 70 يوما
شهيدان وقعا في هذا القصف كان داخل
السياره هم من انتشلوا من داخل هذه
السياره انتشل واحد وبقي واحد احترق في
داخل هذه السياره لم تستطيع الطواقم
انتشاله بسبب اطلاق القناصه الاسرائيليه
النار الكثيفه داخل هذه على هذا المفترق
رقم محاوله الطواقم التقدم لانتشال جثمان
الشهيد لكن النيران لم تسعفهم ولم
يستطيعوا انتشال هذا الشهيد بسبب النيران
الكبيره القصف المدفعي الذي استهدف هذه
السياره تسبب باشعال بشكل عنيف وبشكل كبير
جدا وهذا الاستهداف هو ليس الاول هو
الرابع في داخل المجمع ومحيط المجمع الان
حتى هنا المواطنون يصرخون على من هم في
قباله هذا الشارع للعوده من الطريق الذين
حاولوا التقدم اليه بسبب وجود قناصه
الاحتلال ووجود قوات الاحتلال على المفترق
الذي يصل ما بين هذا هذين المفترق تحذيرات
كبيره من التقدم في هذا المكان والمواطنون
حريصون على العوده مما من المكان الذي اتى
عليه ال الاشخاص الاخرون من المفترق الاخر
لان قناصه الاحتلال هناك لا تترك احدا يمر
ومدفعيه الاحتلال في نفس اللحظه ايضا لا
تترك احد يمر من خلال هذا المفترق يبدو ان
السياره كانت ضحيه هذا الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي سياره مدنيه كانت تنتقل من
مكان الى اخر واستهدفت امام مجمع الشفاء
الطبي واشتعلت النيران داخل هذه السياره
وكان يتواجد جثمان احد الاصابات داخل هذه
السياره واستطاعت الطواقم انتشال الاخر
رغم اطلاق النار العنيف على هذه السياره
منذ صباح اليوم هذا الشهيد تتزايد حصيله
الشهداء في محيط وداخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
الى 28 شهيدا حتى هذه اللحظات وعشرات
الاصابات بسبب القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصل
على مدينه غزه وبالتحديد مجمع الشفاء
الطبي ومحيط هذا المجمع اسماعيل عندما تم
القصف يعني وقبل القصف يعني
بين الفتره الزمنيه الفاصله بين عمليات
القصف هذه كنت معنا في اللقاء وكانت هناك
تجمع ل اكبر شاهدناه خلفك للنازحين
الموجودين في محيط المجمع وداخل المجمع
اين يذهبوا اين يذهب النازحون كيف يتحركون
عندما يحدث هذا القصف خاصه بان لديهم
الحيره والخوف
والقلق صحيح نحن والنازحون نتواجد في نفس
الخطر لا نعرف اين نذهب صراحه اذا ذهبنا
شرقا في مستشفى المعمداني يتواجد القصف
واذا ذهبنا غربا الى مستشفى الشفاء يتواجد
ايضا قصف في كل ناحيه يتواجد الاحتلال
ويحاول استهداف المواطنون والنازحون الذين
هم ابرياء في داخل اي مجمع تحاصر الان في
ذات اللحظه قوات الاحتلال مجمع لمدارس
الايواء الذي يقع في المناطق الشرقيه
الشماليه لهذه المنطقه للمنطقه حي الرمال
هذه المدارس الان هي محاصره من قوات
الاحتلال لا نستطيع معرفه ماهيه هذا
الحصار رغم القصف المدفعي المتواصل
بالاضافه الى اطلاق النار العنيف الان لا
نعرف الى اين نذهب صراحه نتشاور في داخل
الطاقم هل نذهب بالاضافه الى مناطق غربيه
ام الى مناطق جنوبيه ام الى مناطق شماليه
كل المناطق مستباحه ويتواجد بها القصف
الاسرائيلي حيره كبيره كما نحن في هذه
الحيره كثير من العائلات في نفس الحيره
التي تدور في الاذهان ولا نعرف المصير في
الساعات القادمه او المكان الذي نريد ان
ان ان ان نتوجه اليه من هذا الخطر الحقيقي
لان الخطر في كل مكان حماكم الله اسماعيل
يعني ظروف صعبه جدا حماكم الله في اينما
ذهبتم وين ما وقفتم اي نرجو لكم دائما
السلامه حدثنا اكثر اسماعيل ايضا بالاضافه
الى عمليات القصف المتواصل على محيط مجمع
الشفاء الطبي ووقوع كما قلت 28 شهيده منذ
الصباح فقط عند هذا المحيط محيط مجمع
الشفاء الطبي بسبب هذا العدد الكبير
من النازحين الذين
لجوا اليه كنقطه تجمع امنه من المفترض ان
تكون امنه عن حدثنا اكثر عن ما يجري في
الاماكن الاخرى في مدينه غزه ونحن نعلم
بان هناك صعوبه في التواصل بسبب استمرار
انقطاع الانترنت وشبكات
الاتصال صحيح في محيط مدينه غزه وشمال
مدينه غزه بالتحديد ما زالت قوات الاحتلال
تقصف في مخيم جباليه وتحاول التقدم في ذاك
المكان بشكل عريف وارتكبت قوات الاحتلال
في مخيم جبالي عددا من المجازر بحق مختلف
عائلات البطش عائله علوان عائله عائلات
اخرى ايضا في ذاك المكان لكن بالتحديد
مدينه غزه في المناطق الشرقيه الشماليه يق
حي التفاح وفق وفق ما وردنا ان قوات
الاحتلال ارتكبت الكثير من المجازر في ذاك
الحي لكن لا تصل الطواقم الطبيه لذاك
المكان وصل بعض المواطنون صباح اليوم
واخبرونا بالمجازر التي ارتكبت بق بحق
عائله الشواه بالتحديد وقصف قوات الاحتلال
لعدد من المنازل وا ضرب الخزانات بالنيران
وافراغها من المياه بالاضافه الى تعطيل
الخلايا الشمسيه علما ان هذه المناطق لا
يتواجد بها اي نوع من الاتصال حتى الطواقم
لا تستطيع الوصول الى ذاك المكان ولا اي
مواطن التحرك بكل سهوله خاطرت هذه العائله
لايصال بعض الا الاصابات الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي انتقالا الى منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان
ومنطقه ابو اسكندر هذه المنطقه التي تواجه
تواجه الكثير من القصف المدفعي بالاضافه
الى الكثير من المجازر التي ترتكب لكن
التغطيه دائما ما تكون نادرا ما تكون انيه
بسبب صعوبه الوصول الى ذاك المكان وصعوبه
الوصول الى الاخبار يخبرنا المواطنون بعد
ايام بهذه المجازر بسبب انقطاع التواصل
والاتصال لكن الان المجازر الاكبر في
منطقه حي الصبره بالقناصه الاسرائيليه
وطيارات الاكواد كابتر بسبب تواجد الكثير
من المواطنين يصل الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي
ما بين فينه واخرى الكثير من هذه الاصابات
برصاص القناصه من مفترق الثلاثين ومفترق
الطيران بالاضافه الى الكثير من الاصابات
بطائرات الكواد ال كابتر المسيره هذه
الطائرا را الخطيره التي تقتل المواطنين
بشكل متعمد وبشكل مباشر تتركز في منطقه حي
الصبره ومحيط منطقه الرمال ويصل وصل صباح
اليوم الكثير من الاصابات من هذا المحيط
ولا ندري ما هي هذه القصف الذي يقع ايضا
في تلك المنطقه بسبب قله المصادر و وصعوبه
التواصل من وصعوبه الوصول الى ذاك المكان
مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول نتمنى لك السلامه
انت والطاقم والجميع حيث ما
كنتم في هذه الظروف الصعبه جدا جدا وغير
الامنه على الجميع شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلنا
اسماعيل الغون من مجمع الشفاء في مدينه
غزه